[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
r les papeete est sacripant sont les
amis des enfants vers les côtes est et
sacripant sont des gens charmants sacré
pensionnat vent mais pas toujours qu'un
enfant envoient leurs un message pour
voir si tu n'es ça c'est du lourd
[Applaudissements]
voulez-vous que je vous dise perles et
pop at elle va tout ça n'est pas drôle
est ce qui n'est pas drôle sacripant
notre appel hier comment tu n'es pas
d'accord avec moi
si si galipeau pet mais malgré tout
avouer que de ne plus avoir jamais de
chocolat de bonbons de noisette
bah c'est pas un n à venir au chanteur
sacripant soyons sérieux une petite
minute
si vous croyez du envie de rire seize de
persifler je ne siffle pas permis pop
est d'abord commencé à m'énerver non
mais je n'ai pas la moindre de vos
intentions
reprenons donc as-tu d'une seule fois
manqué de quoi que ce soit non vers l'ip
est bon n'as tu pas eu la bonne soupe
quotidienne aussi alors bon
madame lipopette ne te prépare t'elle
pas de délicieuses gâteries aussi
souvent que possible
ah si c'est bien vrai bon chaque fois
que nous sortons ensemble ne tache pas à
faire des bonbons des glaces et des
gâteaux
aussi c'est bien pour ça que je vais
aller me promener avec vous alors je ne
suis qu'un saut habitat incapable un bon
à rien je me plains tu toujours sans
raison je critique sans arrêt je
pleurniche jeu ne vaut même pas la peine
d'être jeté aux chiens à sa non alors je
n'en voudrai pas même un jour de disette
à à meulan grotte daddah a allégé bien
que je t'aime bien et tu n'es rien tout
ça c'est bien vrai de vrai mais oui me
win tin kg est pas tu auras plus de
bonbons que tu ne peux en manger et bien
voilà tout à fait rassuré ouais non rêve
alors il est temps de commencer le
palmarès 1
bonne idée
[Musique]
non il y a de l'orage dans l'air
j'ai vu pire mouais en page
hier enfants sages
c'est trouve à rosny-sous-bois dans la
seine saint denis
ce premier enfant sage que ça tétouan
fait me désigne et une petite fille son
prénom commence rs comme solange non pas
les pas du tout elle s'appelle sophie va
lario 4 rue gay lussac 93110 rosny sous
bois se fie à 6 ans est une enfant qui
aime l'école car on apprend à lire et à
faire de beaux dessins nous dit elle ah
ben ça c'est bien vrai c'est bien vrai
elle n'est pas toujours très gentille
elle est très ordonnée sa chambre est
toujours bien rangé et quand sa maman
est un peu débordé dans ses travaux
ménagers
elle passe le balai fait les lits et
elle sait faire toutes sortes de gâteaux
aussi oui oui on allait très bien cet
enfant est le très bien je l'inscris
nous sommes arrivés à arnouville dans le
val d'oise
cette fois c'est un petit garçon qui a
été choisi par sakory papeete dont il
est sage sans prénom commence par p
comme patrice et bien ça fait pas
beaucoup mieux
il s'agit bien de patrice blondel 7 bis
rue du commandant marchand 95 400
arnouville il a quatre ans vous avez vu
pearl hip hop at il un gros lapin sur
les genoux oui ça ne m'étonne pas c'est
un enfant qui adore les animaux
il nous dit de ne pas trop manger de
chocolat parce que nous pourrions être
malade
évidemment évidemment c'est ce que je te
dis tout le temps mais la seule liste
itude de patrice me touche
oh oui je l'inscris
on est dans le morbihan
oui à locminé je parie que c'est un
garçon oui c'est cela
tu as gagné celui-ci est il son prénom
commence par c'est comme cédric oui
c'est cela cédric jégou 21 sites et
arc-en-ciel 56 500 look mines
c'est un tout petit garçon de 2 ans il
est un peu turbulents mais très très
affectueux
ouais on est toujours un peu turbulent à
son nom
et puis il m'écoute il mange sa soupe
après l'émission et a pas et hop au lit
à sa maman lui fait un câlin et ils sont
dans aussitôt on dirait presque que vous
y étiez c'est le coeur qui parle
sacripant en ce moment il dit instruit
cédric alors voilà qui est fait sa
crypte est à trouver un enfant sage à
issoire dans le puy de dôme en deux
petites filles qui se sont distinguées
cette fois ils apprennent on commence à
rennes et s comme nathalie et solange
je pense que ça c'est presque ça
s'appelle nathalie et sophie michaud 14
rue du mas 63 500 issoire nathalie à 5
ans et sofia 3 ans elles sont ravis
d'avoir été choisis tu peux me croire
c'était lors plus cher désir alors elles
sont à l'école et sont bien sages
oui mais il ne range pas leurs jouets
oui bon il faut faire pour faire un
effort les enfants pouvaient un effort
bon d'abord canton en revanche passé
joué et bien on les casse c'est très
bien ça crée pas ça c'est très bien très
bien oui
bon ben je vous inscrire toutes les deux
voilà nous sommes dans la baie leur
pêche à le teil
alors nous avons encore deux enfants une
fille et un garçon
il a deux prénoms commencent par p
comme patrice et patricia ce sont deux
jumeaux de 2 ans patricia et philippe
brottier saint martin sur la mesure où
la faisons pas besoin 074 sans le teil
il regarde le palmarès tous les soirs
avant d'aller se coucher
philippe est très sage il joue toujours
tranquillement dans son coin
patricia et plus agitée elle n'écoute
pas toujours elle fait pas mal de
bêtises mais là gros des papes et relie
pop at elle promet d'être sage
maintenant bon alors inscrire et vous
fini nous sommes à livron dans la drôme
et notre dernier frein dida est un petit
garçon sans prénom commence par des
comme david david vernet 67 rue du
perrier 26 250 livres ont ils à 6 ans il
est toujours dit gentil quand sa maman
travaille il reste à la maison tout seul
car son grand frère frédéric est en
pension il ne fait pas de bêtise peut
très bien
eh bien mon petit david je t'embrasse et
goethe inscrit voilà et maintenant le
grand moment est arrivé
david vernet de livron patricia et
philippe rochot tier 2 le teil nathalie
et sophie michaud d'issoire c'est blick
j goodluck mines patrice blondel
d'arnouville sofival are you de rosny
sous bois
elle est vite trouvé votre porte un
préposé des ptt vous y attend pour vous
remettre un colis plein de jouets comme
ceux ci n'ont elles et manger votre saut
à dali pop est très bien ça fait pas
très bien bonsoir les petits enfants
sages bonsoir